Rich Eisen joins us now welcome to the
holiday party rich thanks for joining us
you have peyote in your eggnog what are
you guys doing over there that exchange
you know what that sounded like to me
with fritzy coming out in this robe you
know that was like that Goodfellas well
I thought you said you was all I thought
it no I didn't say I was all right now I
thought you said you was all right
spider I said that really that's what
that exchanged out of me I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry you had to hear well
welcome to the party though well Dan I
really I didn't bring anything but thank
you though you fit in with everybody
else very good okay we had this topic
yesterday few topics but one was whose
career would you want to have Dan
Marino's or Eli Manning well obviously
that's the the quintessential one has a
ring and the other one doesn't have one
I don't know how you turned down Dan
Marino's career I just don't know how
you do that with all those records and I
know that Eli has the career so I'll go
Dan I'll go Dan Marino he played in a
Super Bowl he didn't win one he's got
tons of records he's a pro Football Hall
of Famer first ballot which I prophecy
you I won't be and and he was a an Ace
Ventura pet detective nobody could take
that away from him tan laces out the Tom
Brady story the timing of it I thought
was interesting because you just beat
Pittsburgh you don't like distractions
you've got a distraction you got two
more regular-season games but what do
you think happened that would lead Bill
Belichick to say I'm gonna kick
Tom's health guru off the plane and off
the sidelines I have no earthly idea and
normally that would be a story that
would subsume a franchise going for a
you know a Super Bowl but the Patriots
put velvet ropes around their team and
just and just knock it all down I have
no idea what the heck happened right
there and ordinarily like I said this
would be something that people keep
asking them questions I saw some
exchange was somebody asked him this was
similar to him being a parent and trying
to keep one of his show
away from somebody that that wasn't
beneficial to their to their well-being
and he just like stared at the guy and
goes why would you bring my children
into this it means a perfect exchange
right there to the point where where the
back-and-forth ended with the reporter
Rapala gisin for being a his question
being a poor one not season the way
things go in New England
seaton play it when Rich is talking
about the exchange between the reporter
in the Belichick let me get let me get a
fork and knife and stick a napkin down
my shirt it's getting great here we go
thank you see that these trainers like
if your adult son was a child who's
hanging out with somebody you didn't
really care for all that much don't try
all these supposed to say my children I
don't think that's appropriate here I'm
trying to coach a football something
that kind of frustrates you because it
takes the focus off of him and he walks
off in the reporter says I'm sorry was a
bad question yes it was we we've had
this reporter on Paulie haven't we
marked Dondero yes but he was very proud
of his questions he's a repeat offender
yeah yeah it's the one who comes across
like he's the the the dude who tries to
deal with Hans Gruber and die hard is
that that guy the same guy
Bubbe but being done you tell Ellis bill
bubby is it my pronouns answer my
question Ellis Ellis it doesn't work
well worked out well for Ellis bubby
spider by the way and Goodfellas so Todd
should watch it all right 19 teams are
still alive yes is this a good thing
yeah this is gonna be great I mean right
now damn do you do does do the folks at
your shop have an idea of what game 256
might be right now no no you might
Circle that what that Falcon Carolina
but I mean he's you know NBC in the
league don't really want it to be for
seeding they want they want a win or go
home situation Tennessee Jacksonville
might be that yeah III honestly don't
know what that final games going to be
there's a lot of teams in it
you got 110 win team in Jacksonville
that's already clinched in the AFC and
310 win teams in the NFC haven't
clinched a thing yet they all have win
in in scenarios this weekend but the
Falcons can crash that party and you got
the Cowboys trying to gay run that few
people thought possible with Ezekiel
Elliott coming back and potentially the
window of opportunity for Seattle as
we've known them of the the Pete Carroll
era I think that was the end of the
first iteration of the Russell Wilson
Seahawks we're gonna see a second
iteration of them with what's going to
happen in this offseason Philip Rivers
has got a shot here a legit shot because
the bills that are in front of them at
eight and six wait go back to what you
said about siano what do you think that
do think Pete Carroll is gonna stay
there you know I do are you doing there
no yes I think you're about this second
iteration of Russell Wilson Pete Carroll
that may be some of the Legion of boom
players may not be back right now I was
you know we were calling it on gameday
morning Lisa because everybody's
everybody's injured pretty much except
for old Thomas I think you're going to
see some changes there on that roster
but no I don't think Pete's going
anywhere but the Pete Carroll the Pete
Carroll team that we've known with the
defense as we've known them and and
Russell Wilson with the players around
him you know you have to do something
about that run game if do do something
about the offensive line maybe some of
these players on defense don't come back
I think that you're seeing a team in
Seattle that's playing desperate
football in Dallas this weekend in a
must-win game for both of those teams so
there's still a lot of really intense
action with a lot of chips yet to fall
so I like this you don't the 19 team no
I I do
I just like I'd like to have established
you know their little separation there
that that I know mathematically that a
lot of teams you know these teams not
all nineteen teams have great odds of
making the playoffs but I like it's a
little separation I think it feels it
still feels like it's the Patriots and
then everybody else do you feel that way
you know DB twelve this van is the
reason why and you know and and at some
point the Steelers are going to end up
playing a Tom Brady Patriot team and not
lose one of their key players either in
the middle of the game or going into the
game
maybe Antonio Brown comes back healthy
enough and the Steelers get that bye
week and they're just one went away from
having to go back to Foxborough I can
give you this scenario as you take a
look at the teams that are in the
playoffs potentially in the AFC most
likely and you've got the Chiefs who I
know have been bounced from Foxborough
before but if they show up in the same
manner that they showed in week one I
think that would be a much tougher game
than people think and then the Ravens
have had considerable success in that
building close close calls and and wins
they might show up there and keep
Pittsburgh at home for the AFC
championship game I mean that's entirely
possible
but you know it does feel like the
Patriots are just always going to be a
step above everybody not only because of
Tom Brady there's one thing that I don't
think a lot of people have talked about
because we're lost amongst the cache not
a catch and then you know Big Ben saying
I wanted to spike it but then I heard a
voice in my head and it was a coach and
blah blah blah is the Patriots
defensively we're ready for this
situation they're one of the most
situationally terrific teams and and all
that I'm hearing this week is that is
that Belichick tells all his receivers
do not dive for the goal line because
you could see what happens otherwise you
get benched so that's another reason why
they're tough to beat yeah the fact that
they were prepare
for that even the fact that he's telling
his players don't do what these other
these other receivers are doing and that
is reaching for the goal line the
potential to lose the ball have it go
out of the end zone for a touchback is
you know there's no no detail left you
know unchecked no box there or stone
unturn it's it's it's incredible what
they've been able to do tremendous Spurs
might be the only other team in sports
that are come close to being
situationally brilliant in any scenario
that that you could think of I mean they
really are brilliant and that that that
comes into play in crucial moments like
we saw this past week and in the most
crucial game of the season
he's Rich Eisen from the NFL Network and
also the Rich Eisen show and he'll be
joining you at the top of the hour on
DirecTV audience channel 239 rich what
games do you have this weekend the Colts
and the Ravens on NFL Network on
Saturday
please watch right after that and then I
got to tell you that that Christmas Day
game right around middle of October when
deshaun Watson was crushing it and
Pittsburgh at Houston we were circling
this for Christmas Day and you didn't
think that we'd have TJ yates against an
Antoniou brownlow Steelers but it is
what it is as they say in the NFL and
we'll be there for it yeah big one for
Pittsburgh they have to have it thank
you rich how is that for sale job
unbelievable 10 out of 10 10 Merry
Christmas thank you rich that's Rich
Eisen for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]